uh let me talk briefly about the
discussion forum for david pakman show
viewers and listeners and audience
members on reddit at david pakman.com
slash reddit re d di t i really want you
to go over there and subscribe and
participate in the forum we're
approaching two thousand individual
subscribers there and every day now
there are interview suggestions being
posted there are suggestions for the
show there are ideas for different
elements of the show viewers are arguing
with each other i've talked about this
before let's just go through some of the
discussions on the reddit discussion
forum in the last few days one post
points out our research about beverage
industry funded research that downplays
the connection between soft drinks and
obesity and diabetes i've talked about
this many times the the all of the
industries that are tied into sugar have
long funded research to cast doubt about
the health impacts of that in a really
interesting post and article and
discussion about that on the reddit
discussion forum also discussed on
reddit uh comments about producer pat
and we have a user who posted hat is
killing it but he shimmies and i think
what they pointed out pat is that
sometimes when you talk it's like you
kind of into it and you're sort of
moving around right i think that's what
they're pointing out well you know what
happened the first couple weeks that i
was on the show I noticed i was a bit
lifeless i wanna wear things up a bit so
this just kinda came with the the nature
of changing it up but i calmed it down
now clearly one person very nervous as a
result of that uh but uh again the
unread it all topics are fair game and i
know you jumped into the comment and
said hey yeah this is something that has
been pointed out and it's really good
because same day for the most part you
and I are checking out what the stories
are and figuring out what's on the
audience's mind right and for me I mean
I was mostly positive reinforcement
which is glad to see it was a ninety
percent positive comment forget about
all right also very detailed feedback on
reddit about my interview earlier this
week with libertarian economist Steven
Horowitz I won't read you this
incredibly long wall of text but suffice
it to say this was a
really good and detailed sort of
critique about uh my interview with that
libertarian economist we had another
user post to Reddit sort of unsure about
whether I'm now pronouncing Nevada the
right way we we had this conversation
about the right way to say Nevada not
Nevada Nevada anyway this user is unsure
that I'm even saying it the right way
now and then lastly a really really good
post about legalization and
decriminalization of all drugs uh saying
hey you know I'd like to explore a
little further why some progressives
think that legalization is the solution
to the drug epidemic and a very good
conversation happening about that so
please go to david pakman.com slash read
it re d di t subscribe there and jump
into the conversation because there's
really a lot of very very interesting
stuff happening there